[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
July 25th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
parents paying tuition for two or more
children in college could lose some
financial aid under new government rules
wsj personal finance reporter Oyen
adedoyan joins me so oyan how does it
work now if a family has more than one
child in college at the same time
with the current system the information
that parents plug into the free
application for federal student aid also
known as the FAFSA is what's used to
determine how much a family can afford
to pay annually that's a number that the
education department calls the expected
family contribution that number is then
divided by the number of siblings that a
family has in college in order to
estimate how much a parent can
contribute per sibling oh so they're
taking into account the size of the
family yes the entire family unit is
what's taken into account with the
current Formula okay so take us into the
numbers a bit what is this formula about
and how does it work in terms of
affecting students applying for
financial aid so let's say for example
a family is determined that they can
afford to pay ten thousand dollars a
year with one child in college if that
same family now has two children in
college that expected contribution is
going to be cut in half to five thousand
dollars per kid that increases each
student's ability to qualify for a
financial aid for example so what's
changing under the new rules now that
discount so to speak is going away so
the education department is no longer
going to
include the number of siblings in
college as a factor in determining
whether or not you qualify for more Aid
now you spoke to families who are
affected by this what do they tell you
yeah so the interesting thing about this
is that some families are going to lose
out on financial aid that they may have
qualified for in the past but others are
actually going to be more able to
qualify for financial aid so one mother
I spoke to in Tennessee has three kids
her oldest daughter is already in
college but her younger two aren't too
far behind her
her and her wife make a combined
household income that's over 100k so her
oldest daughter didn't qualify for any
Pell Grants or other types of federal
student aid however she has another
daughter that's about to graduate high
school and she was kind of hoping that
when her daughter now comes into college
and her youngest son then follows behind
her she would begin to qualify for those
sibling discounts which would make
College overall more affordable for that
family why is the government pushing
these changes through
these changes are really part of a
greater goal to simplify the FAFSA the
current system is pretty clunky and
complicated for families to navigate
through so the new FAFSA is going to
have different questions it's going to
be a lot shorter and it's going to be
directly connected to federal tax forms
so how is this related to students
eligibility for other financial aid like
the Pell grant that you mentioned a
moment ago this new formula is going to
expand access to
like the Pell
grudents than ever are going to be able
to qualify for this and that's what
financial aid officers were telling me
how is this likely to change the overall
College expenses picture for families
for some families this is really going
to change the financial aid award that
they're used to getting every year for
those families that I mentioned earlier
with multiple kids in college at the
same time they may see a smaller
financial aid package than they've seen
in previous years and that's going to
mean that they're going to have to reach
out to their own financial aid offices
and inquire about ways that maybe that
number can be adjusted from the
institutions level how many families
could be affected by this change roughly
one-third of families have siblings that
are in college at the same time so
that's not to say that all of those
families are going to be affected but a
great deal of those families will be
thirty percent of the country's families
have got more than one child in college
yeah it's a big chunk how big of a shift
in the rules is this has this sort of
thing been done before financial aid
officers told me that this is going to
be a completely new FAFSA that no one
has ever seen before so this is a big
change for them and they're scrambling
right now trying to figure out just how
much this is going to change for
families but they anticipate there's
going to be a lot of questions and
they're going to get an influx of calls
from families as well once this comes
out who are confused about the new
system and when will this change take
effect this change takes effect with the
new FAFSA which comes out in December of
this year and is applied to the
2024-2025 academic school year
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Oyen adedoyan and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you